yo what's up my name is Samuel leaves my
friend owns this house this house is
awesome I want to introduce you to my
man Ryan Ryder doctor I'm Ryder very
good friend of mine he bought this house
it's a by refurbished refinance property
he's gonna put his money in he's gonna
pull his money out and right now he's
going to talk to you about the figures
so stay tuned
hey guys my name's dr. Ryder I'm a
property investor and I'm here in
Burnley close to Manchester showing you
one of my property deals I'm just about
to do so look behind me we're gonna
convert this bad boy can take 13 beds
student let I'll take you to Porter
inside in a moment but let me tell you
about the figures first the other
numbers we're purchasing this building
behind me this bad boy for two hundred
seventy five thousand and we're gonna do
a refurb on this before in the vicinity
of two hundred to two hundred fifty
thousand pounds the done a failure at
the end is gonna be in the vicinity of
702 703 vet HMO all ensuite making me to
nine thousand pound cash every single
month that's net cash flow and I've got
no money left in the deal I'll pull that
sound right this is your picture let me
show you around
we got a big project yeah but it's super
exciting
the dark is getting darker right now so
bear with me but you'll see the extent
of the reefer that's needing them good
news about that is wherever there is not
unity when you see a building that needs
extensive reefer
that also gives us a huge opportunity to
add massive value that's what's so
excited about by refurbishing planets is
I'm gonna be able to take over running
back so again getting the property for
free at the end of the day we've got a
great University at Burnley I mean if I
have change to live in something like
this hours of students Heelys student
digs we're gonna have a games room we
can have awesome games areas etc so come
on
so as you can see we have a lot of work
to do in here but the good news is we've
already we've already stripped back a
lot not too much work to be done on this
the the we've had a couple coats for
builders and all coming into that
facility of those figures I said between
200-250 etc depending on the border
we've already stripped back a lot of the
carpets the walls are now Glastonbury
and and as I say a lot of work to do
here but it also gives us a great
opportunity
[Music]
Wow okay have a look so we've just come
from the ground floor ground floor four
bedrooms we're gonna have a lounge on
the ground floor and a kitchenette on
the ground floor on the first floor got
a lot of work to do here but we're going
to turn this there's also gonna be four
bedrooms around here there's actually a
study room there's a study room that's
gonna be created here remember every
single rooms gonna be ensuite we've also
got kitchen it on the second floor then
we've got a third floor which you can go
operate in the moment and give it about
12 hey guys we're on the third floor are
we going to turn this into five double
bed on Suites total 13 bedrooms and
tight think um have a look around we've
really stripped back a lot of walls and
nice sized rooms really nice sized rooms
already I mean some of the things I mean
we've got a big refit yeah but you can
see we've really got something we can be
able to reuse a lot of this and to bring
our cost out of our refurb and you see
it flips all the way around and we're
gonna get the full five bedrooms on this
floor which really pretty cool so I hope
you guys enjoying the tour just to give
you a good understanding of what a buy
refurbish refinance can look like this
is quite a substantial one but super
exciting and it's kind of deals I like
to be involved it so I hope this is
helpful
[Music]
so one of the great things about this
property is that the layout stays pretty
much the same it's basically just the
fit up across the board come over look
we've got lovely views across the church
and we're in the center Center tally
we've come in to push the center yeah
Burnley most important thing for me
there's gonna be a student lit and it's
gonna be close to the University so I
already offer quite a few student later
I love student less a lot of people
don't necessarily like them I like them
because almost having zero voids with
any of my student list so I'm really
excited about this project the
university literally up the road left
and ten minute walk which is amazing for
this property and what we're gonna be
able to do with it
one of us interesting things about this
project is that here the key things
shift instead barbar refurbish refinance
one the structure is all sound that's
been checked I think we have one tiny
area in the building we have to put a
new steel in second the roof is good
condition we can reuse the roof we don't
have massive costs there or extra costs
there and then planning which is very
unique for this probably was already
done on the property so I've got to
purchase as property planning done which
made my job a lot lot easier and a great
little project for me to get stuck into
this is a great example of not money
down deal yes they need some capital to
get into the deal but at the end of the
day I have got zero money left in the
deal and have cash flow every single I'm
to a half thousand pounds every single
month now here's the thing a lot of
people watching this and going how about
how do I get the initial capital well
this is where you have to have the skill
set of budding investors which we teach
exactly how to do at the crash course
and advanced programs and there's no
guarantees in anything but within within
a reason you know exactly what you're
gonna be putting in watching and getting
out and how you gonna pay your investors
back so specifically for finding
investors for this deal great deal I am
gonna be doing all by myself but if you
will want you to do a completely no
money down deal where you don't even
have to care to come as the capital to
start the deal we're getting this whole
thing bridged but you could do that with
the finding in in this is very easy for
this deal one of the other great things
about raising finance for a deal like
this is when you go to investor you
literally I don't know your term already
because speech about do you know how
long the reef is going to take you're
bridging finance is going to be over set
term already your interest repayments is
going to be accrued towards the end
anyway so when you're able when you
go to your finance we're raising finance
you able to say to your investor listen
we're gonna get your money back to you
in six months time even when you know
the project might be done in three
months time give us a little bit more
time for that we're building oil takes a
little longer than you think
etc but again you're going to invest and
say I'm gonna get your money back on it
with your return in six months time as
opposed to most investors have
opportunities to get their money back in
five years time that's just a great
position to be in to go look invest X
amount and you get this much back in six
months time I mean that's incredible hey
guys we're in the basement of the
project to be doing is they're in
Burnley and this is going to be turned
into a games room a kitchen a study room
and a lounge amazing area for people to
come hang out I'm so excited about this
project you don't be able to see much
because a pretty dark but have a look at
most I think is a worked on er about 130
pounds per week per room but really
speak to local state agency or regular
agents gonna be helping us manage this
place that do lots of shooting it's in
the area there's gonna be nothing like
it in area I mean we're literally
walking distance just for the university
that they think that we're gonna get be
able to further away from 135 to 150 per
week so again you know going into the
investment I've been super conservative
I know that the very least we're gonna
be making tuna half grand cash flow but
if we get that hundred and fifty pound a
week per room then we smiling so great
news great news from the agents guys I
hope you liked the video did you enjoyed
that and you want to see more content
like this please smash the like button
also if you want to learn through the
same thing if you want to meet Ryan and
people like Ryan then don't forget to
book onto their property investors crash
course you can do that right here
right here right here book book on book
on book on I'll see that
you